clothes panel is a highly scalable
externally consistent and globally
distributed database creating an
instance and connecting your application
to it is fairly straightforward
providing an excellent troubleshooting
experience for the database queries in
an equally simpler sequence of steps is
quite essential too last year we
launched query insights which provides
an easy way to quickly identify top
queries by CPU utilization and analyze
those queries in detail but what if you
want to compare execution plan for
queries across instances
today we are excited to announce the
preview launch of query plan samples a
powerful visual tool for visualizing
query plans for historical query
executions not only does it let users to
quickly visualize plans for selected
queries but also compare execution plans
for instances of the same query allowing
developers and database administrators
to quickly understand why the aquarium
is performing differently across
different executions
let's check it out with a quick demo
to access Cloud spanner go to Google
Cloud console and on the search bar type
spanner once you select that you should
be able to see Google Cloud spanner
console on the left you see the Explorer
pane on the right you land on the
overview page
before getting into query insights and
query plan samples details
let's first ensure that we have the
instance database table and data
required for this demo let's take a look
at the query insights for my application
workload that's connected to an instance
in Cloud spanner
query insights dashboard helps users
identify expensive queries by showing
total CPU utilization for all queries
and for the selected database listing
top n queries and tags represented as
graph and also in the form of a list the
top CPU utilization query that we see
right here is the query that my
application workload is running
so I'm going to click the fingerprint
link to narrow down into the query
Details page
the query Details page for the selected
query displays execution count and
average CPU in milliseconds average
latency in milliseconds average rows
returned average rows scanned and
average bytes and right below that is a
new section that we have included now
which is query plan samples
as you can see here there are dots that
represent the different points of
execution of this same query that is
under observation
the x-axis represents the time and the
y-axis represents the latency in our
case we can notice that at 4 13 PM the
latency has been low
and at 4 16 PM it's increased to 696.26
milliseconds this represents a dip in
performance starting 4 16 pm
let's find out why by clicking on a
specific dot on this query plan samples
graph we would be able to see the query
plan on the right hand side of this page
and you can also expand it to a full
screen mode for the query execution at 4
13 PM we can notice that there has been
an index scan it has had a latency of
19.19 milliseconds
the same query at 416
has gone through a full table scan as
opposed to the index scan
on order item table and has had a
latency of 642.27 milliseconds
this only means that the index idx
underscore price was suddenly dropped in
between the two execution points of the
same query and spanner is no longer able
to use the index to quickly find the
rows that match the query criteria
instead it has to perform a full table
scan which is a much slower operation
to fix the performance issue I just have
to create the index idx underscore price
back on the table
and spanner can use the index to quickly
find the rows that match the query again
and now in the query plan for the latest
execution of the same query we can
notice that the performance of the query
is back on track with an index scan low
latency of about 19 milliseconds
as a developer it helps for me to
understand quickly why the same query
performs differently at two different
points of execution it helps developers
and database admins to quickly narrow
down into the root cause of the issue
and address it at the tip of their
fingers so why don't you try it out in
your application today and find out why
your application queries perform or
behave differently at different points
of execution use the link in the
description to read more about it